[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit einer
zimmermann und christian sievers guten
abend hinein was da jetzt in peking
beginnt in einer gegend denen der ist so
gut wie nie schneit zumindest nicht auf
natürlichem weg das wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen
es sind olympische winterspiele in der
pandemie und bei gastgebern die panische
angst davor haben von einer omikron
super sprayer walze erfasst zu werden
die deshalb zu nie gekannten und nie für
möglich gehaltenen mitteln greifen weil
sie ihr land und ihre macht der welt
präsentieren wollen
gleichzeitig bleibt es für viele die in
erster reihe mit dabei sind schlicht der
höhepunkt einer sportkarriere
das große ziel nach jahrelangem training
kann man ausgerechnet von athletinnen
und athleten erwarten jetzt die spiele
zu boykottieren
müssen sie jetzt harte kritik üben an
den zuständen im gastland weil die
internationale sport bürokratie das
nicht tut und bei der vergabe von
olympia nicht an menschenrechte denkt
sondern an das große geld die
politischen winterspiele von peking
christiane hoffmann berichtet
an historischem ort auf pekings platz
des himmlischen friedens offenbar dieser
fahnen appell wieweit präsident das land
auf sich zugeschnitten hat kurz vor
beginn der winterspiele haben die
chinesischen athleten ihrem präsidenten
geholt dicht wie die chinesen einst nur
dem ersten kommunistischen führer mao
für das mutterland geben wir unser
bestes wollen das volk nicht enttäuschen
wir werden alles tun um unseren großen
vorsitzenden etwas zurückzugeben wir
folgen ihm in eine gemeinsame zukunft de
voran
propaganda die ganz auf die
kommunistische partei und präsident lee
ausgerichtet ist selbst bei den
olympischen spielen wie der gerne in
historischen dimensionen denkt hat dafür
gesorgt dass peking die weltweit erste
stadt ist die sowohl winter als auch
sommer spiele austrägt alles folgt
seinen vorgaben
unser leistungssport muss den gleichen
weg nehmen wie unser land um groß zu
werden
olympische spiele als staats plan und
weit mehr als ein sportereignis china
feiert auch sein politisches system eine
propagierte überlegenheit über westliche
demokratien präsident hier erscheint als
visionär und macher der spiele
ich glaube schon dass das wirklich nur
bühne ist die ehe auch bewusst nutzen
will das geht einerseits nach innen um
das signal dass er wirklich dieses neue
china führt ins neue zeitalter als
supermacht und das andere ist nach außen
das signal dass hier noch selbstbewusst
wirklich in der internationale rolle
annimmt und auch etwas stemmen kann was
andere länder nicht stemmen können das
internationale olympische komitee macht
mit trotz massiver
menschenrechtsverletzungen in hongkong
tibet und xinjiang das ioc bleibt
kritiklos wie präsident bach versteckt
sich hinter olympischer neutralität
übernimmt bis ins detail hieß setzte 300
millionen chinesen wird nun wintersport
treiben so bach und scheune china
beginnt mit den spielen eine neue ära
für den globalen wintersport
bei der veröffentlichung des berichts
zur nachhaltigkeit der spiele lobt bach
in einer videobotschaft die
organisatoren der bericht zeige dass bei
der vorbereitung
nachhaltigkeit auf allen ebenen
integriert worden sei dass für die neue
bobbahn und alpine ski piste ein
naturschutzgebiet zerstört wurde wird an
keiner stelle erwähnt kritische
nachfragen werden nicht zugelassen nicht
soll das bild von den umweltfreundlichen
spielen stören kritiklos chinesische
propaganda erlegen so erscheint das ioc
unterbach von sheva der wohl auch
deshalb als guter freund chinas gelobt
und ihm eine büste gewidmet schon vor
beginn der winterspiele
ja vielen athleten geht es also neben
den sportlichen herausforderungen vor
allem um eins negativ bleiben lucas bögl
ist der beste deutsche langläufer der
letzten beiden weltcup winter ist und
seine zweiten olympischen spiele erst
gerade in peking angekommen jetzt hat er
sein zimmer bezogen im olympischen dorf
herr bürgl show guten abend
am 1 was hat sie denn erwartet jetzt als
sie ankamen in peking können sie das mal
beschreiben bitte
zuerst einmal aufgefallen das so sagen
was das laufen die
komplette montur kleidung sind sie sich
erst mal ein bisschen verstört aber ich
muss sagen die abfertigung am flughafen
hat man sich noch mal tippen schlimmer
vorgestellt er habe es geschafft von
flugzeugkomponenten
bus gesessen sind innerhalb von drei
stunden zu schaffen den lassen gepäck
technik ist es ist nicht so dramatisch
gewesen
die ganzen kontrollen der test die davor
gelaufen sind die mir daheim machen
mussten sind alle schon online gewesen
hochgeladen total das war relativ
schwierig hat uns auch teams zusammen
gemacht und ganzen abend die kosten zu
bekommen aber das hat dann hier
wie geht es denn jetzt weiter was wird
da jetzt wird täglich von ihnen verlangt
abseits natürlich der sportlichen
vorbereitung
durch die täglichen kroner test
hier schon das erste negative ergebnis
bekommen wo er doch noch gar nicht aus
dem zimmer bewegen und erst dann wird
weil sie zum essen gehen und so
funktioniert und jetzt ist natürlich
hier
man kommt aus diesem dorf nicht aus dass
wir sind entweder in diesem oder einem
weltcup stecken also dass und
eingesperrt und es im test und dann das
anfangen sich zu akklimatisieren
zeitungen und ins training starten
haben sie denn angesichts der
bedingungen die sie da jetzt schildern
das gefühl wirklich diesen olympischen
geist spüren zu können bei diesen
olympischen spielen auch wenn sie das
vergleichen mit den letzten spielen bei
denen sie dabei waren
ja da muss ich schon sagen auch jetzt
hier ankommen in das deutsche quartier
die deutsch fallen
vorbereitet das hat dann schon ein
tolles tür einfach auf uns dieses bild
im dorf der dann trotzdem auch den
carola maßnahmen auch jetzt spüre dass
es sind alle es bleibt ein ergebnis also
auch wenn wir darum weniger ist und die
keine zuschauer auch nicht zu viele
zuschauer aber das erlebnis gleich
bleibt groß und sportlich
am 6 februar ist ihr erster wettkampf
für bürgel alles gute für sie und
herzlichen dank dass sie heute bei uns
wollen
die rennrodlerinnen david berger ist im
präsidium der sportler vereinigung
athleten deutschland guckt also quasi
von außen auf all das sie selbst ist
nach einem sturz und einer zwangspause
wegen einer corona infektion nicht in
peking dabei frauenberger guten abend
erst in gut die deutschen olympia
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer die haben
eine ganze reihe dringender warnungen
bekommen im vorfeld auch lucas bögl mit
dem wir ja gerade gesprochen haben er
unter anderem vom militärischen
abschirmdienst was steht denn in diesen
warnungen drin
ja an diesen warnungen geht es konkret
um
die meint die tour ab die einige
sicherheitslücken aufweist und da ging
es darum
[Musik]
gesundheitszustand zu verfolgen über 14
tage bevor der anreise und aufgrund der
mängel
ist natürlich auch nicht die sicherheit
gegeben dass alle daten die sich auf
mobiltelefonen auf laptops oder
ähnlichen befinden eben wirklich
gesichert ist und man darauf eben
zugriff hätte und dass natürlich dann
auch nicht sehr schön ist das ist eine
app der organisatoren der olympischen
spiele richtig genau diese notwendig
vorher zu installieren um den
gesundheitszustand
aufgrund der kurve pandemie eben zu
dokumentieren und die dann auch wichtig
war so einreise haben sie das schon mal
erlebt dass man als sportler vor
olympischen spielen quasi gewarnt wird
sein eigenes handy mit zu bringen ich
selber kenne es vielleicht sogar nur aus
science fiction filmen und habe 2018
ganz andere olympische spiele erleben
dürfen wo das keine rolle gespielt hat
nein das internationale olympische
komitee sagt wir haben mit politik
überhaupt nichts am hut es geht uns nur
um den sport was sagen sie dazu
meiner meinung nach kann man das ganze
überhaupt gar nicht mehr voneinander
trennen also es ist ganz offensichtlich
dass nicht die athleten danach gefragt
werden wo olympische spiele stattfinden
wenn wir die ganze lage rund um china
betrachten nicht nur die kurve situation
sondern auch das thema der
nachhaltigkeit und die menschenrechts
problematik dann
ist das natürlich ein sehr gebündeltes
thema und alle themen auch nicht von der
politik wegzudenken also auch nicht im
bereich einer so hochrangigen
wettkampfes der die aufmerksamkeit der
ganzen welt auf sich zieht sagt david
berger von der sportler vereinigung
athleten deutschland freut berger vielen
dank ja danke
und die gespräche haben bei wegen der
zeitverschiebung grund aus termingründen
vor dieser sendung aufgezeichnet es gab
heute auch echten
aufsehenerregenden geschichte
schreibenden sport und zwar beim tennis
in australien dazu später mehr bei diana
erstmal müssen wir uns mit dem wetter
folgen hier in deutschland beschäftigt
und zwar mit dem sturmtief nadja
das hat vor allem über nord- und
ostdeutschland gewütet und dabei schwere
schäden angerichtet
mehrere menschen wurden verletzt im
brandenburgischen beelitz kam ein
fußgänger ums leben er wurde von einem
ungewählten wahlplakat getroffen
sturmböen entwurzelten bäume es kam zu
unfällen und teilweise wurde der
bahnverkehr lahmgelegt laut dem
deutschen wetterdienst wurden
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 127
stundenkilometern gemessen das sturmtief
nadja führte außerdem zu
überschwemmungen die weser trat über
ihre ufer der bremer stadtteil vegesack
unter wasser in hamburg hatte sich ein
schiff unter einer brücke festgefahren
es solche geflutet werden damit es
absinkt und herausgezogen werden kann
die bergung dauert noch an
es ist ein historisches treffen zum
ersten mal überhaupt ist ein
israelisches staatsoberhaupt in die
vereinigten arabischen emirate gereist
israels präsident herzog wurde vom
außenminister der emirate empfangen
danach traf er auf den kronprinzen
mohammed bin sajid in dessen palast bei
dem gespräch soll es unter anderem um
eine engere zusammenarbeit bei handel
und technologie gegangen sein er ist
seit 2020 hat sich das verhältnis
zwischen israel und dem golfstaat
normalisiert
der grüne tübinger oberbürgermeister
boris palmer will für eine weitere
dritte amtszeit kandidieren
dieses mal allerdings als parteiloser
das gab palma auf seiner website bekannt
wegen umstrittener aussagen droht palmer
bei den grünen der parteiausschluss
nach der vorgezogenen parlamentswahl in
portugal bleibt die sozialistische
partei von amtsinhaber antonio costa
ersten prognosen zufolge stärkster kraft
costas linke minderheitsregierung hatte
nach einem gescheiterten
haushaltsentwurf nach nur einem jahr
neuwahlen ausgerufen
laut den prognosen konnte costa sein
ergebnis im vergleich zum letzten wahl
verbessern wäre aber auf
koalitionspartner angewiesen
auf den tag genau 50 jahre ist der
sogenannte bloody sunday in nordirland
heute her mit einem gedenkmarsch haben
zahlreiche menschen im nordirischen
derry british london derby an die opfer
von damals erinnert es wurden kränze
niedergelegt und es gab eine
schweigeminute
13 katholische demonstranten wurden am
30 januar
1972 von britischen soldaten erschossen
es dauerte fast 40 jahre bis die
britische regierung eingestand dass die
demonstranten unbewaffnet waren die
ereignisse des bloody sunday trugen
damals dazu bei dass der nordirland
konflikt weiter eskaliert
während sich die halbe welt sorgt wegen
eines möglichen krieges in der ukraine
wird die tourismusbehörde des landes
unruhig weil keine urlauber mehr kommen
bleibt ruhig und besucht die ukraine
heißt die neue werbekampagne
zitat die ukraine ist ein attraktives
fantastisches spezielles land mit
unterhaltung für jeden geschmack es gebe
keinen grund für panik es gebe nur viel
zu wenig positive nachrichten das stimmt
die einzigen die sich in den hotels von
kiew die klinke in die hand geben im
moment sind internationaler diplomaten
auch großbritannien verstärkt jetzt sein
engagement während deutschland weiter
streitet wie der ukraine am besten
geholfen sei außerdem ist natürlich viel
presse da krisen reporter für uns
christian sen
ein paar hundert ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer sind heute mittag zum ei dann
platz in kiew gekommen um danke zu sagen
danke an die internationale gemeinschaft
für die unterstützung während russische
truppen an der grenze kriegsangst
verbreiten doch eine flagge fehlt die
deutsche zu den versprochenen 5000 helm
sagen sie ihr höflich danke aber sie
wollen waffen
verdammt wir machen das doch alle
zusammen wir sind europa wir sind das
vereinte gebiet und ich kann nicht
verstehen wie man nicht erkennen kann
dass es weiter gehen wird wenn russland
ein feld und die ukraine besiegt wird
russland wird in der europäischen union
weiter machen
deutschland argumentiert mit der
geschichte und seiner verantwortung das
argument verstehen viele hier nicht
ich möchte sagen dass es unfair ist dass
deutschland russland als einziges opfer
des zweiten weltkriegs betrachtet im
gegenteil die länder die näher an der
deutschen grenze liegen bitten mehr wie
die ukraine die russische propaganda
liegt sie schreibt die geschichte
ukrainische parlamentarier haben einen
brandbrief geschrieben an den deutschen
bundestag und appellieren an deutschland
waffen zur verteidigung zu liefern
wir bieten ja nicht um truppen auf
ukrainischem boden aber andere länder
davon abzuhalten die ukraine mit waffen
zu versorgen das ist und entschuldigen
sie dass ich das so sage widerlich
was tun bei einer russischen invasion
was aussieht wie ein spiel ist purer
ernst seminare für den ernstfall haben
gerade hochkonjunktur auch in kiew
2014 waren wir überhaupt nicht
vorbereitet und jetzt ist es für mich
besser zu wissen wie ich mich verhalte
und wie ich mich vorbereitet hätte meine
verwandten meine freunde
vor den toren der hauptstadt proben sie
den krieg auch mit holz gewähren
professoren journalistinnen arbeiter
oder ärztinnen sie rüsten sich für ein
gefecht mit russland als freiwillige wir
haben keine angst sagen sie aber wir
wollen vorbereitet sein
in mehreren städten deutschlands ist das
wieder ein wochenende mit protesten
gegen die korona maßnahmen ganz im
südwesten in freiburg im breisgau waren
es bis zu 4500 menschen die
demonstrierten friedlich und ohne
störungen sagt die polizei in leipzig
sah das anders aus dadurch brachen
mehrere dutzend menschen eine
polizeiabsperrung und stürmten das
gelände einer klinik
und das hier sind bilder heute aus dem
äußersten osten von deutschland görlitz
der aufmarsch dort war unter anderem von
der rechtsextremen kleinst partei freie
sachsen beworben wurden zu sehen auch
fahnen auf denen steht donald trump hat
gewonnen
der neue ostbeauftragte der
bundesregierung war gerade in sachsen
unterwegs er will sich seinen teil
dieses landes ganz genau anschauen und
er will zeigen dass das amt mehr sein
kann als eine stelle für frühstücks
direktorin christiane hübsche hat ihn
begleitet
carsten schneider ist angekommen im
sechsten stock des bundeskanzleramts
kein ost beauftragter vor ihm saß hier
im zentrum der macht keiner vor ihm
hatte den rang eines staatsministers
oben drüber ist dann quasi die leitung
ist dass olaf scholz und direkt die oben
drüber ist der chef des bundeskanzlers
und wolfgang schmidt also vielmehr geht
es nicht nach 24 jahren für die spd im
bundestag packte schneider die kisten
der kurze dienstweg zu scholz als signal
der osten sei jetzt wirklich chefsache
eigentlich sollte das amt wie immer
heißen beauftragter für die neuen länder
aber das fand schneider in thüringen
geboren nicht mehr zeitgemäß und ich hab
dann klaren und oder falls gesagt was
auch wo das macht das gerne aber wir
sagen ostdeutschland dazu und ich möchte
auch gern dass es so heiß weil die leute
sollen schon wissen worum es geht und
was auch werden ob in diesen wochen
stellt sich der neue ostbeauftragte in
seiner hälfte des landes vor gleich der
erste antrittsbesuch geht nach sachsen
die erwartungen an schneider hier sind
groß und deswegen ist es unglaublich
wertvoll einen partner zu haben wie den
staatsminister schneider der weiß
worüber spricht der die dinge selber
kennt und der sich für uns zum anwalt
auch in den ministerien machen wird
dabei ist schneiders macht begrenzt er
bringt kein geld mit hat kein eigenes
budget kann in berlin nur der
fürsprecher des ost noch sein von mir
können sie erwarten dass ich mitgebracht
habe ist die feste zusage dass die
ostdeutschen interessen eben im
kanzleramt einer spitze mit verortet
sind wie dünn das eis der ostdeutschen
befindlichkeiten ist erfährt carsten
schneider gleich in seinen ersten
amtswoche als er in einem
zeitungsinterview über die ostdeutschen
sagt die demokratische praxis des
aushandeln von kompromissen ist ihnen
fremd geblieben gleich hagelt es kritik
wo doch der neue weniger polarisieren
wollte als sein vorgänger wanderwitz ich
muss noch sehr präziser formulieren ohne
zweifel eine verkürzung die ich mir das
abwandern habe erlauben können eben
sicher machen sondern einsatz hinten
dranhängen und das geht im osten auch
und eine klare sprache auch zu sprechen
und auch noch nicht beleidigend tragen
und auch nicht nicht besserwisserisch
schneider kommt früh im westen an 1998
wird der gelernte bankkaufmann mit 22
der bis dahin jüngste
bundestagsabgeordnete in bonn im
plattenbau in erfurt groß geworden als
sohn einer allein erziehenden der sich
für seine ost biografie nie geschämt hat
meine familie viele arbeitslose von
daher glaube ich
ich mache die die vier jahre bundestag
wenn ich sehe ich kann alles bewegen
mache ich weiter ein ostdeutscher
aufstieg zum haushaltsexperten der
spd-fraktion zuletzt parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer
jetzt will er ein paar der dicken alten
bretter bohren wenn man sich die löhner
anschaut kommt auf die bundesdeutsche
karte man sieht immer wieder die ddr
nämlich mit den geringen einkommen das
muss sich dringend ändern
schneider ist einer von vier
ostdeutschen am kabinettstisch von olaf
scholz erfordert mehr seiner landsleute
in spitzenpositionen ohne quote dafür
mit mehr mut wir wollen dass verbessern
es ist auch wirklich zwingend notwendig
wenn ich ein kleines bisschen doch auch
ein vorbild sein kann dass das geht ja
also aus den plattenbaugebieten er war
tatsächlich her zu kommen ohne vitamin b
zu haben wie er dann
die in den bereichen waren
wäre schon viel gewonnen mindestens die
hälfte seiner zeit will der neue
ostbeauftragte durchs land reisen neue
bilder des ostens prägen und möglichst
vielen eine stimme geben
unfassbar historisch sensationell die
nachrichten überschlagen sich bei dem
was rafael nadal da heute geschafft hat
aber
er brauchte zeit viel zeit das kann man
wohl sagen ganze fünf stunden und 24
minuten so lange hat es gedauert bis
feststand der spanische tennisprofi hat
die australian open gewonnen und mit
diesem 21 grand slam titel ist nadal nun
außerdem alleiniger rekordhalter in
einem packenden match besiegte der 35
jährige den russen mit vegf kein profi
vor ihm hat das geschafft rafael nadal
setzt sich nach unglaubliche
energieleistung an die spitze der
bestenliste dabei hatte dani medwedew
gegen den im vergangenen herbst und
winter wegen einer fußverletzung
ausgefallenen spanier schon wie der
sichere sieger ausgesehen mit diesem
ballwechsel sichert sich der
weltranglistenzweite aus russland den
zweiten satz im tie break nachdem er
bereits den ersten mit 6 zu 2 gewonnen
hat
doch nadal beweist mal wieder
unvergleichlichen kampfgeist holt mit
gesteigertem risiko satz um satz auf
nach fünf stunden und 24 minuten hat
nadal dann tatsächlich matchball zum 7 5
im fünften satz
sein 21 triumph bei einem
grand-slam-turnier
auch in abwesenheit des weltranglisten
ersten novak djokovic eine wahrhaft
sagenhafte leistung
beim skisprung-weltcup im hessischen
willingen gab es wegen wind probleme nur
einen durchgang bei den frauen katharina
althaus landete auf dem zweiten rang
hinter der slowenin nica krishna beim
anschließenden springen der männer stand
er sind günstiger im nun stattfindenden
zweiten durchgang überzeugte der
oberstdorfer karl geiger und flug auf
dem zweiten rang hinter dem norweger
marius sind weg platz zwei übernahm
geiger auch wieder die führung im
gesamtweltcup
so und jetzt nimmt sie unsere frankreich
korrespondent in crystal haas mit auf
eine schnitzeljagd für modefans es geht
einmal quer durch paris gleich sechs
museen und ein ziel dem vielleicht
größten modeschöpfer seinerzeit ein
denkmal zu setzen
exakt vor 60 jahren hat ein gewisser
yves sarault seine erste kollektion
gezeigt der rest ist geschichte eine
geschichte voller ideen und erfolge der
mann hat tabus gebrochen und
konventionen und manchmal brach ihnen
das leben selbst das schönste
kleidungsstück für eine frau sind die
arme des mannes den sie liebt hat er
gesagt für die dieses glück nicht haben
bin ich da
es ist als seien sie teil der großen
gesellschaft auf dem wandgemälde diese
glänzenden ruben dieselben farben
dasselbe leuchten das kunstwerk ist von
1937 die kleider von 1992
die sonne hat sich für seine kreationen
häufig von der kunst inspirieren lassen
an diesem gemälde faszinierten ihn die
pinselstriche betrug sie auf seine
kleider
lisa [ __ ] bei einer der mit konventionen
brach und die motor revolutionierte bei
ihm trugen die frauen mondrian zum trotz
[Musik]
die profis verloren hat vieles
übernommen aber daraus immer ein eigenes
kunstwerk geschaffen er wollte die
vergänglichkeit von mode überwinden und
stattdessen einen stil setzen für ihn
war der stil ewig die mode aber
kurzlebig
vieles was er den frauen auf den leib
schneiderte ist tatsächlich
unvergänglich der safari look
überhaupt hosenanzüge
und natürlich der smoking für frauen
damals eine provokation heute
selbstverständlich auf jedes wort
[Musik]
er machte die frauen elegant die frauen
waren maskulin und gleichzeitig super
feminin
seine mode ist basic aber sehr gut
gearbeitet selbst nach 20 jahren kann
man noch seine kleider tragen sie werden
immer beliebt bleiben
korobow das seine modelle jetzt in
gleich sechs der bedeutendsten museen
von paris gezeigt werden hätte ich so
lorang wohl sehr gefallen er hat viele
seiner entwürfe und skizzen für die
nachwelt aufgehoben
er war der erste modeschöpfer der
erkannte dass seine arbeit bewahrt
werden musste schon in den 80er jahren
hatte ein m auf manche zeichnungen
gemacht mw museum
und immer wieder die kunst die in seine
kreationen einfließt picasso braque
die malerei davon war er überzeugt
sollte musste das leben der menschen
begleiten für die jacke mit van goghs
sonnenblumen fielen übrigens 600
arbeitsstunden an
ausgefeilt und perfekt dass schnitt
können aus mode kunst machen sagte ich
solle ernst und hat damit recht behalten
[Musik]
mode vergeht stil bleibt ewig auch der
satz ist von ihm und gilt für ihn wir
gucken jetzt nach vorne auf das was in
der kommenden woche wichtig wird simone
friedrich macht das im heute-journal
ausblick
[Musik]
die hohe inflation dürfte den
bundesbürgern das leben weiter schwer
machen so die einschätzung der
bundesbank grund dafür seien unter
anderem die stark gestiegenen
energiepreise das statistische bundesamt
gibt zum wochenbeginn die inflationsrate
für januar bekannt
eröffnung der olympischen winterspiele
in peking am freitag fast 3000 athleten
treten an skispringer karl geiger gehört
zu den deutschen top favoriten ebenso
bobpilot francesco friedrich oder auch
die rodler mit johannes ludwig und julia
taubitz
am 6 februar 1952 hat königin elizabeth
die zweite den britischen thron
bestiegen am sonntag vor 70 jahren die
feierlichkeiten zu diesem rekord
thronjubiläum sollen allerdings erst
anfang juni stattfinden der palast plant
ein viertägiges spektakel mit parade
live konzert und partys über corona
beschränkungen wurde nichts gesagt
nun der blick auf die wetteraussichten
morgen bleibt es ungemütlich zeitweise
gibt es kräftige schneefälle bis ins
flachland die später in lagen unterhalb
von etwa 500 metern wieder zunehmend in
regen übergehen
im westen und süden starker bis
stürmischer westwind im bergland gefahr
von schneeverwehungen ein bis sieben
grad die weiteren aussichten sehr
wechselhaft und windig bis mittwoch am
alpenrand unwettergefahr durch starken
schneefall und schneeverwehungen am
donnerstag beruhigt sich das wetter 0
bis 10 grad
ungemütlich ist vorhin gesagt also
bestes fernseh wetter wir sind auch
morgen wieder für sie da für heute
dankeschön und gegen 00 25 gibt es hier
die nächsten nachrichten in der heute
express von uns allen an sie einen
angenehmen sonntagabend
[Musik]